Hello, and welcome to this introductory class
into Lighten inside of Unreal Engine 5.
My name's James Burton, and I'm an Unreal Engine instructor.
I'll be guiding you through this course
and covering a wide variety of topics regarding Lighten.
We'll be going through Lighten terminology.
We'll be going through the differences between baked
lighting and lumen.
We'll also be looking at Nanite and virtual shadow
maps, as well as some baked lighting setups
that we can take a look at in order
to have a good holistic view of how lighting works inside
Unreal Engine and what the options are available to us.
So I hope you enjoy it, and let's get started.